The security situation playing out
before the former president
has turned himself in
on those charges in Georgia.
Sources tell us that
most likely to happen next week
as his legal team is working out
the details of his surrender
at the Fulton County Jail.
Let's discuss this
case, broader
implications with former Trump
White House
Press Secretary Stephanie Grisham
and Republican election lawyer
Ben Ginsberg.
Good to have you both on today.
Thanks so much.
Stephanie, I want to ask you this.
You look at the doxing of these jurors
you look at these threats, for instance,
to get against the judge here.
The former president has attacked
the system.
He's attacked the judges.
He's made personal and public attacks
against some of the witnesses
in this case.
Has he helped to give license by his own
public attacks
to this kind of behavior
in these kinds of threats?
Well, absolutely.
I mean, and
you can look to January six,
I think, as a huge, huge example.
But, you know,
what gets me is that I know
very few
Republicans want to upset Donald Trump
in any way right now.
But I'm asking,
why are there no Republicans,
most specifically
the people running against him
for the Republican nomination,
calling on him
to put something out, to say
there should be no violence,
please do not threaten
anybody having to do
with my criminal many criminal cases
Please do not threaten the jurors.
How is it
that there's absolutely
not any Republicans out there
that I'm aware of that
are calling on Trump?
All of them should be calling on Trump
to say something
because I think that will also
show voters
who he really is, that
he won't keep quiet
or he won't say anything.
He'll stay quiet
and allow people
to continue to be threatened.
Yeah, it's a good point
because it's exactly
what folks were asking for
on January six.
Right, for a public statement
to call back to the rioters.
Ben, I think many people were surprised
to learn
that under Georgia law,
grand jurors identities,
they are released,
listed in public court documents.
That's the way it is.
I wonder if that law survives
the current time we're in.
Is that, from your perspective,
someone who's participated in many cases
and you're well aware of the politics
around our systems today
and the public threats to them.
So that change
Well, look,
the incentives behind releasing the names
was a good one.
It's because you do
want some transparency
in your government.
But it was also ruled
it was put in
in a very different time from now.
And so
as you see,
these grand jurors
who did do their civic duty
now come under harassment and attack,
there will be a rethinking
of all these laws.
So it'll be a little bit of transparency
in our government that gets taken away.
Another institutional sort of denigrated.
Yeah.
And it's it was there for a reason.
Right.
But but the threats might very well
outweigh it.
But, Ben, another question for you
before I go back to Steph.
Stephanie,
you've heard
a lot of this whataboutism,
which is,
of course, a new national sport,
but some people are now
making comparisons
between Trump's attempts
to overturn the election
and the many lies
he shared about false
election fraud and Al Gore's
election disputes.
In 2000
of course, you took part in that
on the Republican side,
as the court
process played out, of course, Al Gore
eventually conceded the election.
Do you consider
those two events at all equivalent
No, not in the least.
Look, the Florida election that Al Gore
contested was 537 votes
under any semblance
of what sort of proper behavior is.
That's an election
that you can contest in recount.
Donald Trump went ahead and contested it
and asked for a recount
and brought litigation,
and he lost every one of those 63 cases.
And the bargain in in that situation
is that you can take the cases to court.
You have every right.
But in going to court,
you also have to abide
by the decisions of the court.
Donald Trump failed to do that.
Al Gore conceded the election rightly
and properly.
And Donald Trump has continued
to basically tear down
the institution
of American elections
with unfounded charges.
Stephanie, advisers do not believe
Trump is planning to take part in next
next week's
presidential GOP presidential debate.
What do the other GOP candidates
need to do there to stand out
and make themselves a viable alternative
to Trump?
Well, I would
say respectfully,
they need to stop kissing up
to Donald Trump.
That is clearly not working for them.
And, you know, the base,
which is who
they're all trying to appeal to right now
in order
to become the Republican nominee.
They like people who are tough,
clearly look at who they're
they're going for
right now in Donald Trump.
But how are people supposed to think
that these people,
these nominees are going to stand up
to somebody
like Putin
or Kim
Jong un
or even some leaders
of our allied countries
or members of Congress
if they won't stand up
to this one middle
and actually older man.
So I think that's something
they need to do. They need to change.
They need to pivot.
They need to just
not only talk about their policies,
they need to call him out and show
that they have the the backbone.
I'll just say that to do it.
We'll be watching for that backbone.
Stephanie Grisham.
Ben Ginsberg,
thanks so much to both of you.